next berkshire hathaway chairman and CEO
Warren Buffett talks about the US
economy and the challenges facing the
global economic recovery he spoke with
the president of the Economic Club of
Washington David AM Rubenstein
and down announcer
okay thank you very much Warren for
coming this evening and honoring us and
I don't think you need much of an
introduction but I guess we'll say that
I think it's fair to say that you are
the most respected investor in the world
and I think the most respected
businessman in the world not just
because you've made a great deal of
money but because you've done it with
enormous integrity and humility and as
people will see tonight with enormous
sense of humor and in addition to being
a business person that everybody would
aspire to be he has recent years become
the with Bill Gates and Melinda Gates
the largest philanthropist in the world
I think his net worth might be in excess
a little bit higher than mine I'd say
about fifty billion dollars more ten
more or less and he's committed to give
99 percent of that away and he's in the
process of doing so so thank you on
behalf of the country and everybody else
for doing that
your background is pretty well known but
some people may not know that you
actually spent much of your formative
years in Washington DC your father was
elected to the Congress so you moved
here you went to Alice Deal junior high
school got a lot of seasoned DS as I
understand and then you went to Woodrow
Wilson High School finished 16th in your
class but you were class of 17 we might
add right well you had you were working
you were doing you were delivering
papers in the morning and delivering
papers in the evening and so forth and
my question really to begin is that many
people grew up in Washington loved
living here and they want to stay here
so they hope to aspire to be the head of
a lobbying firm someday or they have a
congressional staff or something do you
ever have any regrets that you might
might have never make something of
yourself had you stayed here well I'm
still young David I may come back
alright I went out to Alice Neel today
first time I'd been there in 65 years
and I met the principal I went to Wilson
also today but but at Alice II and I
tried to get my record expunged but I
had no luck
well you told me earlier today that you
lived in Spring Valley yeah I lived at
49th Street between Van Essen for
tomorrow via and so today with the
camera crew you knocked on the door the
person was living your house what did
that person say well we had a good time
I mean the house seemed does shrunk but
chase she was she was very about a
wonderful woman she's lived in the house
for 30 plus years and and we got along
very well and then we retraced my paper
Rock mm-hmm so when you were growing up
in Washington you were already a
business person well I thought so I
didn't get a lot of public recognition
to such but well but so you were making
money and as I understand it you filed
your first tax return when you were 14
years old yeah it was for that it was
for the year when I was 13 and our final
two when I was 14 okay and did you think
the tax rates were too high then or it
hurt more in those days i I didn't he
ducked my bicycle and my watch as
business expenses and and only because
the statute of limitations is blind I
took an entire that parent I never used
my bicycle for pleasure or my watch I
never looked at my watch accepted what I
voted papers yeah so after you graduated
from Woodrow Wilson you then went to
actually the University of Pennsylvania
for a year and a half and then you
transferred back to the University of
Nebraska why did you leave Penn it was a
great business school why did you leave
yeah I just I felt I would I mean I
wanted to quit after one year to be the
honest answer on my father talk to me he
kind of talked me into going at college
in the first place and then he talked me
into going a second year but he said if
I went a second year then I could I
could drop out and so then I went back
to Nebraska that way I got out of
college in three years and so it's been
things up and I plan to live in Nebraska
so when you graduated from university
braska you applied to Harvard Business
School and were rejected that's true
has Harvard ever announced that they've
regretted that this woman I understand
the development officers kind of unhappy
so you rejected by Harvard you went to
Columbia Business School and then you
met the man who you really idolized Ben
Graham and when you took his class was
he as great as you had thought he was
going to be he really was the only he
only taught one semester one class I
mean he came up from Wall Street and
taught this class that's the reason I
went to Columbia and he I knew what he I
do I'd already read all the books and
everything so I think but it was
inspirational just to be around him and
I would made a real difference in my
life so when you graduated you wanted to
go work for him and in his firm and then
he rejected you for an interesting
reason in those days I understand that
they were Jewish firms and non-jewish
firms and his was a Jewish firm and you
weren't Jewish so he said because you
weren't Jewish he didn't hire you is
that right that's true he's and I I was
ready to convert believe me up I think
they buy the fellas a little phony at
the time something I but it was it was
true that there were very few firms in
Wall Street that would hire Jews at that
time and then only employed five or six
people but he told me that they sent
that they had were able to employ five
or six people they really felt that the
Jews could not get into most jobs in
Wall Street and that they were going to
employ only Jews well his name was Ben
Graham but actually his real name was
Ben gross bomb well as parents in that
name yeah my my son is named Howard
Graham Buffett named after Benton and
he's very glad that Ben's Papa changed
his name so you moved back for a while
to Nebraska but then he ultimately
changed his mind and you went to work
for Ben Graham I kept pestering him yeah
I made a real pest of myself and in
those years what did you aspire to do
what you do you aspire to become a very
wealthy person would you want to be
buying as thocks would you want to buy
companies what was your aspiration in
those early days I loved I loved just
analyzing securities I just spent hours
and hours and hours just I kept turning
the pages of Moody's which instead of
going you know you had no internet than
anything else so you had two sources of
information Moody's and Standard &
Poor's on and we happen to have these
sets of Moody's they were about in
aggregate probably about 8,000
about five different manuals and I went
through those page by page and Mahlon
must've been exciting TOA yeah and it's
a little strange I mean you know I I
actually went to Amazon a few years ago
and I found an old 1951 moody's now
everybody else was going there for
Playboy magazine but I'm [ __ ] during
the old movies uh got a straight guy
here well when you were working in New
York you were in tracted - one of the
companies that Ben Graham was involved
with which was Geico absolutely I
understand you came down and knocked on
the door what guy Cohen you just started
talking with them and yeah it was it was
really a lucky day I went I would I was
a bit clumsy University Library and I
looked up Ben in Who's Who in America
and it had a whole bunch of things but
it said chairman government employees
insurance company so I asked the
librarian how can I learn more about
this I never taken any courses in
insurance and he said well there's this
big best manual if you read that you can
find out about the company there was one
page on government employees insurance
so that's Saturday I got on the first
train and they came down to to
Washington and I went to the
headquarters of what was then called
government employees insurance and to my
total surprise the place was locked
I mean people didn't work in people no
more worked on Saturday people who watch
the signal work on Saturday so I've kept
pounding on the door and finally a
janitor came and I said to the janitor I
said is there anybody here I can talk to
except you now he didn't seem to get
offended to that particular introduction
so he said there's a fellow up on the I
think sixth floor and he's the only one
here and he was a man named Lorimer
Davidson and Lorimer Davidson changed my
life in a big way it was a wonderful
wonderful man and he talked with me for
maybe four hours on a Saturday and gave
me an education like I never got in
school and so you liked it so much you
eventually bought the whole company it's
one of those things yeah it took a few
years so when you were starting your
investment partnership I think you
started around 1956 with a partnership
that's correct right and as I understand
it if somebody put ten thousand dollars
in in 1956 and it stayed with you and
kept stock that they could have gotten
when you liquidate it's on the
partnerships at ten thousand
worth roughly 500 million dollars today
that's about right Wow yeah so those
people are very grateful to you who did
that right no I was grateful to them
though I mean they were betting on a 25
year old you know who looked about 20
and acted about 12 and then so I you
know and actually they were mostly
relatives on me as my father-in-law and
sister and her husband my hand so your
best friend partnership started you
started buying companies and buying
stocks 'men one of the companies you
bought was Berkshire Hathaway and you
know your company is now very famous its
name Berkshire Hathaway that was not one
of your best investments wasn't it was
really dumb yeah yeah yeah I mean it was
who is what I call us I usually call
Graham's approach on buying very cheap
stocks that weren't very good companies
cigar buds because you it would be like
walking down the street and finding a
cigar but there was one puff left him
and it didn't cost anything it was kind
of disgusting but it didn't cost
anything so but I thought Berkshire
Hathaway was that kind of a company and
it wasn't much of a puff either oh so
you know your company is named Berkshire
Hathaway you've sold that company many
years ago did you ever think of changing
the name no no I don't I don't do much
of that okay so when you started
originally you were buying stocks you
pick stocks but then you started buying
whole companies was that a different
skillset and how did you learn to buy
and operate these companies well when I
buy a hundred shares of XYZ company I I
look at it as buying the whole company
and so I've always looked at buying
stocks as buying businesses so it really
wasn't a different situation now i I
couldn't resell it and I couldn't if I
owned the stock I couldn't change
management's which I could if I owned
the whole company but it was basically
the same approach I'm a better investor
because I'm a business person and I'm a
better business person because I'm an
investor they cross over but the day
Berkshire Hathaway has how many
different companies that are part of the
got about 75 but some of those on more
companies so it's 75 companies you have
about 270 thousand and four thousand
seven current seventy thousand employees
how do you manage all you have a very
small office how many people do you have
in your office managing although we're
now up to 24 we're on one floor we're
never going to leave one floor I tell
them that gonna hire all the people they
want but we're not going to leave one
floor so they want people sitting on
their lap go to it so what you do you
sit in your office during the day
looking at new ideas for companies is
that how you I like to read a lot so I
read I read newspapers and I read all
kinds of financial information and and
basically I'm looking for one good idea
here and do people send you letters over
the transom as any of those ideas ever
work occasionally but not not very often
but I only need one a year where in June
incidentally day but if you want to help
me out
we have a couple companies we like this
Audi but you don't pay high prices but
so in your office do you have a computer
in your office that you it not in my
office but but other people in the
office have them so I know you're not a
famous technology person but do you have
an iPad or do you do no internet things
I do internet things yeah I love the
Internet I mean the internet it's
fascinating to me because it's it's
probably affected my life you know
almost as much as say Bill Gates it we
have a when Bill and I appear together
sometimes we we use the trick question
of aside from email which one of us is
on is on the computer more and the
answer is me because you play bridge I
play vision and every every every night
you've been yeah a couple hours a night
and after all these years of doing are
you a champion no no I'm not even close
I I just have a good time every you know
it's the most interesting game I've
found and if people know that they're
playing with you over the years the name
t-bone and that's it's gotten around
that I am t-bone yeah I used to put my
age is 103 so when I did something dumb
people would say for a guy hundred and
three he's not that but
so you met over the years Bill Gates and
I you first meet Bill what how did you
first meet him I met him in on July 5th
1991 made Greenfield who some of the
people that probably knew how to had a
house out in Bainbridge Island out right
there in Seattle and she'd called me in
the late eighties and she said Warren do
it I love Seattle do I have enough money
to buy a second place and I said make
anybody that calls me an ass does have
enough so ones that don't call so she
bought this house and she wanted to show
it to me that in 1991 so actually K
Graham I Raleigh Evans maybe one or two
others went out there and visited Meg
and then Meg knew the senior Gates's so
she called up Bill senior and Marin
gates and said I've got this crew out
here could we drop down and Mary said
fine and then Mary called up bill and
said Warren Bob was coming down would
you like to come down he said
No what do I have in common with that
guy you know he he doesn't understand
technology he's hopeless and Mary was
very determined that she said you know
you're going to come bill and so they
negotiated a while and finally they got
down to where he said he'd come down for
I don't know an hour and 27 minutes or
something
and and he came down and we hit it off
of here - still talking ten hours later
and we became good friends but he never
convinced you to buy Microsoft stock or
buy technology companies he didn't he
didn't try to he tried to get me to use
a computer and at work
eventually when I learned I could play
bridge on it I got interested in that I
don't understand what happens with it
though I thought he originally said I
get the most beautiful woman dancing at
Microsoft that means that's what he did
but but he was engaged to her so Melinda
didn't work so as you've got to know
bill better did he influence your views
on how to make investments or it
influenced your views on philanthropy I
wouldn't say too much we we we have a
group of maybe 50 people with started
getting together in 1968 we meet every
other year Don Graham was here tonight
as the Buffett group yeah and then at
that at those meetings we would talk
about various subjects and philanthropy
was an important subject so I think it
was maybe in 1993 or something like that
we had a meeting it was in Ireland at
that time and actually brought along the
Gospel of wealth for everybody read we
discussed it then but so our thinking
sort of evolved together in a way but
have you ever regretted not getting
involved in giving away money earlier in
your life or even my wife regretted that
she thought I should she liked the idea
of giving away we both agreed on giving
away all the money I mean once we had
everything we wanted we've had
everything we wanted I mean it you know
and the surplus wealth I have has no
utility to me there's all kinds of you
totally the rest of the world if used
properly so and we agreed on that early
she would have liked the idea of giving
away more of it earlier and I felt that
I was going to be a better compounding
machine than the
than most places and that there would be
a whole lot more to give away later on
so I told her I'll pile it up and you
unpiloted
you know man alright now your father was
a very conservative Republican
Congressmen right you were probably a
liberal Democrat is that a fair well
yeah I would but I was I was always very
conservative but you're conservative are
when he was alive and you later moved
further to the left and would you
compare it's fair to say you're a
liberal Democrat now or yeah I'm not a
card-carrying Democrat I support certain
Republicans that I have and and actually
this year I gave some money to a
Republican congressman and you've been
come famous recently in Washington for
among other things the Buffett Rule
which says that people I guess tax rates
should be at least as high as their
secretaries yeah in terms of the
aggregate of payroll and income taxes I
I couldn't get a disease named after me
so I'd assemble for a tax and if any of
your friends suggested that you
compensate your secretary in capital
gains kind of things so she could pay a
lower rate
she's been suggesting that let me out
right
yeah yeah she's always on the phone with
some tax advisor now no did the
interesting thing is people have
speculated about how much money she made
but the tax rate actually above one
hundred and six thousand dollars for
most people goes out if you take the
aggregate or payroll and income taxes
because the the payroll tax is the most
regressive of all and quits at that
point and so actually between say 106
and 200 in most cases the rate would go
down but your financial acumen is pretty
well known so we now have in our country
15 and a half trillion dollars of debt
in our federal government and 1 trillion
a year or so adding up what would you do
if you were able to wave a wand and try
to fix our debt problem or deficit
problem well I think I would do what
everybody in this room could do I mean
if you ask everybody here how much the
federal government should be raising
annually or in aggregate over the next
10 years the answers would come in
somewhere between eighteen and a half
and 19 and a half percent which is close
to what's been the situation since World
War two if you have so how much the
government should be spending that they
probably come in at 21 percent someone
coming to twenty and a half or twenty
one half there's and incidentally you
can have a two percentage point deficit
relative to GDP and and the debt to GDP
will not grow I mean that in fact it
probably was shrimp just a touch so you
could have a couple percent deficits not
average and I would take the plan that
90% of the people here would come up
with they get to that 19 percent of
revenue at or to get to 21 percent it
can be simpson-bowles it can be a bunch
of different things and no one's going
to agree a hundred percent on every
point but we do I think we do agree on
the fact that we published should be
raising 18 and a half to 19 percent and
we should be spending 21 or there abouts
and that means it means getting more
from taxes and it means cutting
expenditures and the problem is that you
know the Democrats don't want to talk
about what expenditures they would cut
and the Republicans I want to talk about
increasing revenues so would you would
be in favor of increasing the the
capital gains tax or no yeah I would I
would be in favor of that but but we can
come to we're raising we'll say
you know 2.4 2.5 trillion now we have to
raise you know probably three or four
hundred billion more than that and that
can be done I mean we've done it
straight through I mean I've operated
under all kinds of tax rates including
39.6% on capital gains and the country
is growing under all these certainly our
country works but somebody has to step
up and say where it comes right and
we'll come from just talking about
reform doesn't solve anything on either
the expenditure side or the revenue side
I mean you've got to get specific about
it and and like I said I would I bet if
everyone in this room designed a plan I
could sign on to 90% of them and today
the economy in the United States is
thought to be growing about two and a
half percent a year do you agree with
that you think there's any chance of a
recession in the near term I think it's
very low unless unless events in Europe
develop in some way that spill over here
big time but incidentally if the economy
grows two percent a year and population
grows one percent a year that means each
generation is living 20 percent better
than the generation before and it means
in a century people are living 3 times
as well as they lived at the start of
the century so right I mean our rates of
gain and the way people live have been
dramatic in my lifetime I was born in
1930 there's six times the real GDP per
capita as when I was born six times in
one person's lifetime we have a system
that works I mean and it will keep
working you know it may not work at six
times for the next 80 years but it'll
work it'll be two-and-a-half times or
three times
how are you worried about the Euro going
away do you think the Europe would allow
the Euro to go away or that's the big
question I mean have you know Lincoln
said that you know house divided cannot
stand in half-slave a free wouldn't work
and we've got a system words there half
in and half out I mean they're in on
common currency and they're not uncommon
fiscal policy or common culture or
common labor practices and that house
will fall but that doesn't mean it has
to and that means that they have to they
have to reconcile some of these things
it can't be half slave a free now you
invest most of your money
in the united states have you
increasingly been investing outside
between the emerging markets or you're
not as comfortable investing in their
more generous I'm comfortable anyplace I
understand the business well and to some
extent the rules that they operate in
and where I've got the right management
and so I we will buy a business you know
in any one of 40 countries tomorrow if
it's the right kind of business but most
businesses I hear about are in the
United States they think of Berkshire
here we're not we're on the radar screen
here to a greater extent that are on the
world so I understand it's somebody from
Israel sent you a letter over the
transom of one and a half page letter
and you ultimately bought that company
that person was talking about four four
plus billion we bought 80% of it for
four billion and he wanted me to go see
it he told me what a wonderful place
plan he had and everything and I said
I'm not going to go see and I don't go
to I don't go to Iowa you know as far as
I was concerned he said no that he said
you've never seen a plan like this and I
said hey John I said you know I love
your business I love you you know
I'll give you four million dollars but
I'm not going to I'm not going to go to
you yeah I got to start crossing oceans
or anything crazy like that so he said
well if you buy the business will you
come and I said yes so we bought the
business and then I went to Israel it
was everything he said and he was very
pleased and I said yeah I said if I'd
seen this they got to paid you more
money
that's why I'll go visit businesses so
what about China do you invest much
there you go my China very bad we've
been too big and I was sitting in 2002
or 2003 reading the report of PetroChina
and it was fortunately was in English
and I put about 500 million dollars into
petrol China the government of China
owned about 90 percent of it
we owned 1.3 percent so between the two
of us we control the company yeah the
and we made quite a bit of money on it
it was a very very cheap car I mean one
of the huge oil companies in the world
the whole company was selling for thirty
five billion in the market and that was
ridiculous now one of your most famous
investments is Coca Cola you bought
relatively cheaply it's very good for
everybody
now when you don't care where they drink
it just pour it on your neighbours you
but open the cab and where you were a
young boy you you were addicted I was
told to Pepsi how did you switch to coke
well I would like to say of course that
I just finally grew up in our said when
I was a kid Pepsi was 12 ounces for a
nickel and coke with six and a half
ounces for a nickel and if you have any
insights into my personality or not
which I bought so of the investments
you've made over the years at Berkshire
Hathaway one would you say was the
single best investment is there one that
you really are most proud of well the
one I'm probably the most emotionally
attached to is Geico because of a bunch
of reasons but it goes back to a day in
January of 1951 a Saturday and and that
what Norma Davidson did for me changed
my life and they didn't have to do it I
mean I walked in there some 20-year old
kid on a Saturday and he he spent four
hours educating me and then he became a
friend for life and then subsequent
people are jack burn and 20 nicely who's
here tonight I mean it's it's it's just
been a wonderful association whether we
made any money or not but we've done
pretty well on the investment too but it
beyond that it has a special meaning to
me
are their investments that you really
wish you had never done what's your
worst investment
I made a lot of terrible deals and the
worst it's it's hard to probably the
worst he'll be when I make in the future
but the the current title I bought a
company and and instantly I did it I
mean we do not have powerpoints around
or people explaining this stuff to me I
just go and do them and we bought a
company called extra shoe George
Mitchell's here tonight he knows the
company and we paid 400 million dollars
for it which went to zero but we paid
400 million in stock and the stock we
gave up is probably worth maybe three or
four billion today so whenever Berkshire
goes down I feel better about that deal
what about the deals you passed on it
you famously passed on Intel when it was
getting started I thought and other I
knew Bob Bob Noyce pretty well and we
bought it we bought the converts when
they were private or just because of Bob
we bought him at Grinnell College and
the endowment agree now college went
from 8 million to a to a billion dollars
in about 12 or 14 years so and it took
until was help on that but I you know
then in the end I don't worry about
things I don't understand I mean I think
it was Tom Watson's senior said I'm no
genius but I'm smart in spots and I stay
around those spots you know and that's
there's a lot to that and knowing you
your circle of competence is where that
perimeter is is enormous ly important
and you know the fact there are others
all kinds of things I can't do and
there's plenty of companies I can't
analyze but I don't have to worry about
that of all the companies you bought
maybe the one that bought you brought
you the most trouble was Salomon when
you bought it in one point it was almost
in fact put in the bankruptcy and you
had to go and run the company was that
the most difficult experience you had at
Berkshire Hathaway I would say that
probably was yeah that was I was their
CEO for nine months and four days it was
20 years ago I think I remember every
day of it so today when you have all
these managers running your 75 different
companies do they call you every day and
say I got this problem or that problem
or how often do you talk to them know if
they need to call me they're in trouble
they I mean
we buy businesses where the managers
come with them and and there are some
managers that I don't talk to once a
year and there's one I talk to almost
every day but after the one that I
talked to almost every day I would say
the next most the highest frequency
would be maybe once a week but they
always call me I don't call them now
when you want to make an investment you
have a board of directors do you ever
ask them I've heard that you will buy an
railroad for 20-some billion and not
tell your board of directors I told a
few of them okay that was an exception
that I told them I'm not going to have
the know the part of part of why we're
able to make deals is because we we can
act fast they know we have the money
they know we'll do the deal we closed on
October 6th 2008 on a six and a half
million dollar investment in Wrigley and
in conjunction with Mars and they knew
we would have a six and a half million
and that we would close on it eight
people weren't closing on anything and
so it's it's a real advantage to be able
to pull the trigger and and one and if
we have to go through lots of
presentations and everything I mean I've
been on 19 corporate boards and you know
every deal works on the PowerPoint you
know and so it it it's a Show and Tell
type thing and I don't I don't really
participate in it so recently came out
in court discussion that in the insider
trading thing that's going on related to
investment you had made in Goldman right
it came out that you would set the deal
and you told the investment banker this
is the deal and they had to get back to
you but you said don't call for a few
hours because you're going to Dairy
Queen right if your grandchildren is
that right yeah that's true you didn't
want to be disturbed on a deal I just I
knew what I would do and I told them
what I would do if they wanted to do it
fine if they didn't want to do it fine I
mean we we don't really negotiate at
Berkshire it's just I don't have enough
time you know to spend the rest of my
life you know
negotiating with people so I tell them
what I'll do and
if it works fine if it doesn't work find
it now
famously people wonder who will be your
successor and I wonder if tonight you
wanted to give us any insights into that
well I have left the directors of Ouija
board and I plan to keep in contact with
them I don't want to disappoint you but
you're not on the shortlist David can I
be in the long list so we're in perfect
shape for though I would say that we've
got we've got successors that in most
ways are better than I am
but you expect that Berkshire will be
around for twenty thirty forty years
three it's built to be forever and it
has a special culture it has directors
who are committed to that as managers it
would we have an organization would
reject anybody that tried to tamper with
that culture and I think it is special
and they can stay special so today
having achieved all that you have
achieved
you've got the admiration of virtually
everybody in the world for what you've
done
what kind of motivates you to keep going
what are your aspirations over the next
five years or so I'm having the time of
my life I mean I get to do every day
exactly what I like to do with people
who I love and who seem to like me
pretty well and it doesn't get any
better than that I I tell the students
that come to see me and I have 48
universities come out every year I tell
the students take the job you would take
if you didn't need a job and I've got
the job that I but I don't need a job
and I've got that job now you give your
giving away 99% of your wealth you have
three children seven grandchildren and
nine great-grandchildren and any of them
ever say maybe you could leave some of
that to me or they think well I'm
leaving some of it to them and one of
the things I do is that I don't write a
will very often but when I when I write
a will I give it to my children first
before I sign it they all read it
they're they're the executor and I want
them I want two things I want them to
under
stand exactly what's in it and secondly
I want to agree with it I mean and if
they don't I wanted to talk it out now
and we'll figure out what makes sense
and so every I don't know five or six
years or seven years whenever I do this
they read it and sometimes there is
something that they don't understand in
terms of exactly what their duties might
be or something of the sort and then in
terms of equate II got one son that
likes a farm I've got a farm that
they'll get another daughter that likes
the particular house and I've got these
various ways of acquainting that
percentages and all of that and in the
end I think they feel very very lucky in
life so the average person who doesn't
have your investment skills and they
want to not lose their money they would
you recommend that they play the stock
market they buy mutual funds what do you
recommend the average investor well
playing soccer no playing is it not a
word I would choose II I would recommend
that they put a similar sum than maybe
they'd be earning more as they went
along but but save something every month
than just and basically put it in index
fund they are not in a position to make
judgments on stocks themselves they're
not in the game any more than I'm you
know I can I can prescribe in medicine
or something the sort they will get a
good result the American economy is done
wonderfully I mean if you take the 20th
century the Dow started at 66 and it
ended at 11,400 now think of that how
can anybody get a bad result of
investing starting in 66 and 11,400 but
a lot of people do because they jump in
at the wrong time or they think they
know this stock versus that stock but
the average person to just consistently
buy equities which to me are by far the
most attractive Indust my choice around
and they and put it in and they divide
for 20 or 30 years they'll do very well
but you don't subscribe to the efficient
market theory that says the basically
can't beat the stock market you
subscribe to that theory that you can't
or you well if I'd subscribe that theory
right I'd still be delivering papers
Yeah right no no I think I think III I
don't think there's any question that
certain people who evaluate stocks as
businesses can make intelligent
decisions about businesses which will
will enable them to do very well in its
various market but I don't think
somebody that is listening you know to a
TV channel tell them what to do or
somebody jumping around with us chronic
sore or even some sales person who's
getting paid more money for selling them
something and getting them to change
tomorrow is the key to it now you you
gave away or committed to give away the
bulk of your money to a foundation set
up by other people why did you choose
not that just have the money go to a
foundation named after you that
presumably you would control and how did
that idea come about well originally I
actually planned I thought my first wife
would outlive me and that she would give
away the money so that it would have
gone to a foundation that she ran but
the idea was to get the money spent and
you say it's run by other people but if
you know if yes you set up the Ford
Foundation or they set up the Carnegie
Foundation they're being run by other
people just the carnegie didn't know who
they would be or Henry Ford didn't know
they'd be so yeah they are going to be
run by other people if they extend
beyond your lifetime and I I picked
people that I had enormous confidence in
the fact that they had a similar
judgment about where money should go and
and where I thought they would do a
first-class job of administering it and
then I mean in the case of the Gates
Foundation I get people that are putting
up their own money big time
we're very able people are working
full-time out of themselves who aren't
charging me anything and and I've got
these foundations that are run by my
children that it's been wonderful for
them and they each have a separate
foundation so that they can follow their
own interests and not have to sort of
look at you know role logs as to who
votes for this one or that one and it's
all worked out perfectly and what was
Bill Gates reaction when you called him
and said guess what I'm giving you 50
billion dollars eventually I think he
said what I shouldn't joke about this I
don't remember exactly what he said but
he was surprised okay
and did he suggest you put your name on
the foundation as well III don't want my
name on anything you can there are all
kinds of people to do want their names
on it
so if you can sell it to some other guy
why should you give it to me where you
don't get anything out of it you know
hey I understand so as you go forward
now are there certain things that you
would like to accomplish beyond what
you've accomplished or there's certain
social problems you'd like to see being
solved their economic problems or is
your goal mostly to keep your company
doing well and give away the money well
in terms of personally sure I'd like to
I'd like to I want Berkshire I mean that
that is my painting in life I've been
paying it all my life virtually and I
want to keep painting it and haven't
become even more of what it already is
and so that's what I love anything that
anything that works positively for
Berkshire in terms of adding better
businesses you know having wonderful
managers around anything makes them be
in a position to get their full
potential from their companies I love
and I'll do that as long as I can I like
the idea that the basically the fruits
of that you know will be used by some
very intelligent people to improve the
lot of a whole bunch of people who
didn't get the lucky strong life like I
got and how old were you when you
realize you were much better than other
people in picking stocks and in making
these kind of estimates and you realize
that as a young person or did take much
longer before you realize you were much
better than everybody else
it sounds obnoxious but I thought I was
going to be pretty early on well I went
to this period at Wilson I Woodrow
Wilson where I am I was I was really bad
at Alan steel but I was kind of working
out of it or else and I had these
teachers that I caused some trouble to
but they didn't think I knew a lot about
stocks and of course in those days
teachers put all their money in AT&T I
mean that was the ultimate safe
investment so what I was feeling
particularly obnoxious I was shorted a
little AT&T and brought the confirmation
showed it that the teachers may worry a
little but I know I you couldn't you
couldn't love anything as much as I
loved investments and I not get fairly
good at I spent I read every book in the
Omaha Public Library noticed by the time
I was 11 and we will back here as soon
as I got back here and my dad was in
Congress I said get everything and if
library Carter's I want to read it well
there's one company in Washington we
didn't mention
you obviously bought Geico and that's
one of your most famous investments but
you made a very famous investment in the
Washington Post right many years ago
what attracting through the Washington
Post and how long have you held that
invest well I love the business as such
but when I bought the Washington Post
Company this is pretty split they had
about four point eight million shares
outstanding and the stock got down to
sixteen but but thanks to the Nixon
challenge to TV station their TV
stations and a few things that bebe
rebozo on the rest the stock cascaded
down from 37 so it when we bought it the
whole valuation of the America of the
Washington Post company was about 100
million dollars now if you'd asked any
reporter at the Washington Post to go
out to a story on what the Washington
Post company's constituent businesses
were worth they would have come back and
said four or five hundred million so you
were really buying a wonderful business
run by wonderful people at 20 cents er
there abouts on the dollar and you know
it it it's almost a classic investment
if you've asked any of the people who
were selling their stock to us what's
the Washington Post company worth they
would have said three or four times what
it's selling for but they sold it
because they thought it was going to go
down the next day and they were right
for a while but you found that now for
everything that's been 29 years I mean a
39 so you are an optimist about the
future of our country it's a cinch yeah
we haven't lost the secret sauce I mean
yeah go back to that when I was born in
1930 the Dow was 252 of the day before I
was born on a Saturday Friday was 252
that was a high for the year it was
going to go down to 42 there's no
connection in this folks the but you
know if I had seen that my dad my dad
was going to lose his job and and and he
worked in the bank and they were and he
had all his money in that Bank in a
closed and he had no money to pay his
mortgage or anything that was going to
happen within a year if you'd seen that
you said this you know go back and be
like you're Woody Allen movie you know
just don't don't even come out and look
at what has happened since that time I
mean you know we went through a terrible
war with under a terrible depression we
under 25% unemployment with the
thousands of banks closing six for one
you know we're not smarter than the
people in 1930 we don't work harder than
the people 93 we've just got a system
that works that's been working you know
since since 1776 and we'll keep working
Oh any regrets in life not really no and
today you are somebody who very close to
the present States if he asked you to
come in and serve as an advisor would
you do that that it won't happen if he
wants to ask me anything I'll certainly
be I'd always be glad to help but I that
would be true of any president or any
circumstances and today Berkshire
Hathaway is that a buy at this price
well the businesses owns are worth more
than the market price but that's true of
other businesses too well what I'd like
to do is on behalf of everybody here
thank you for an extraordinary
tour-de-force of your explanations of
things and prank you very much for
coming this evening and I think
everybody's had enjoyable evening I know
I certainly did and I want to thank you
on behalf of everybody here and all
America for what you've done and for
your philanthropy and for your
confidence in America and on behalf of
our the Washington Economic Club and our
everybody here I'll give you a few gifts
if I could you may get on that short
list venture this way
this is a Woodrow Wilson High School
jacket we've had made up for you go
Tigers
and and we have here a copy of the
original map of the District of Columbia
we'd like to give to you as a gift from
the club and I'd like to give you as a
personal gift a copy the Declaration of
Independence when we talked about this
appearance you were at the archives and
I think you said you hadn't been there
before it was marvelous
never been there and I cornered you and
you said you weren't sure you what you
would agreed to but you agreed that you
would do this and I thank you for
honoring your commitment to come and
this says it's inscribed to you and it
says Warren Buffett a rare modern man
with the essential traits of our
founding fathers great wisdom courage
and leadership and also great wealth oh
thank you very much she said it right
free at all yeah thank you
ladies and gentlemen please join the
after-dinner reception with cordials and
sweets in the Maryland room and don't
forget to take your complimentary
champagne glass with you and pick up
your gift obey as you depart at the same
evening things are coming
on Washington journal tomorrow morning